he all was really weird about watching
this thing I'm currently in the middle
of my Harry Potter movie rewatched so
hearing the doctor say Harry Harry all
the time was really throwing me off
[Music]
all right folks classic who review time
I know I said that I am moving these
largely over to the oh my god I can't
even think of words anymore over to the
podcast feed and that is still gonna be
the case but some of the big ones the
real seminal ones I still want to do in
video form and it's hard to get more
seminal than Genesis of the Daleks I
remember when I first started getting
into classic who this was one of the
ones that was on all the list of you
must see this one show this one to
non-fans it will help get them into
classic who and I remember watching it
and this was shortly after I got into
new WHO and thinking that was alright
and that was about it
so here was my first thing going in I
suspected and for the most part my
experience bore this out a fair amount
of my problem with when I watched it the
first time is I hadn't yet clicked into
the mindset of classic ooh and come to
terms with the limitations and some of
the things that it just kind of does so
like for example the look of some of the
creatures some of the mutations giant
clams yeah I had a hard time swallowing
that the nature of some of the
cliffhangers I really thought was really
cheap but again that's something Doctor
Who just kind of does and I hadn't to
climb it into that the first time I
watched this so I knew I owned this
thing a proper rewatch to go back in and
be more forgiving of that stuff some of
it I still have issue with and I'll cite
some of that but to get over the things
that just come with classic Doctor Who
because it was a not exceptionally high
budgeted BBC show at this point in the
70s
so yeah I I needed to cut it some slack
this time and I did and this is a very
good story I do think it deserves the
high reputation it has I'm still
probably gonna ultimately call it
overrated
and I probably end up lumping it
together with things like pyramids of
Mars which you know if you haven't seen
my review of that I'll just say
ultimately boils down to look it's not
that it's bad this is not as good as
everybody says it is and you know after
I saw this for the first time I remember
thinking maybe classic error just isn't
for me but I've since found classic
error stuff that I love like unabashedly
no city of death is possibly my favorite
talked to whose story ever
I loved the time warrior I loved tombs
of the Cybermen there's plenty of stuff
that I really really really enjoy but
oftentimes the stuff stuck stuck up at
the top I found myself going I mean it's
good but let's let's dig into this so
the very concept of telling an origin
story for the Daleks is something that
honestly I'm a little bit mixed on
because they're sort of the might in a
vacuum issues but then there's in
context of Doctor Who I'm a little bit
more okay with that and what I mean by
that is broadly speaking this is the end
of in a vacuum thing I find the idea of
a society that as a whole destroyed
itself to be far more compelling than a
society that was destroyed because there
was a lunatic with a bomb and ultimately
you know specific society that is what
Davros is because this is his
introduction this is the first story
with Davros the creator of the Daleks
and broadly speaking I don't find it as
compelling for this massive consequence
of these creatures in these tanks
to basically come down to one guy one
insane guy I just don't find that as
interesting now within the context of
Doctor Who I'm a little bit more
forgiving because they actually already
have another species that serves the
purpose of a society that allows itself
to become something horrible in order to
survive and that's the Cybermen and
accepting the new whom alternate
universe ibis men which I dislike for
this specific reason with the exception
of that the Cybermen who are created by
a single person who forced this on to
the society the society as a whole
got driven to the point where these this
was the collective choice they made so
I'm more forgiving about the
introduction of of Davros because it
does actually help distinguish the
Daleks from the Cybermen cuz otherwise
somatically they bare a little bit more
resemblance and this kind of helps parse
them out a little bit because what is
supposed to be scary about them is
different so that actually ultimately
does work for me and even though in a
vacuum I don't like the single creator
of this race thing it does work and I
will admit to that and also the
character of Davros is well introduced
and has been used pretty well across the
show I will like I won't dwell on this
but I will mention here my nitpick that
I don't like that especially in classic
who going forward from here davits kind
of took over the Dalek stories after
this there was very very few might
actually not even be any I'd have to
look at the list but basically every
story became a Davros story and I given
that he is he is such an you know
centralized and sort of sucks the energy
out of the room character on his own it
does kind of diminish the Daleks a bit
they become his servants almost it was
all it was done more interestingly than
that even across classic who but you
know I kind
don't like that they got saddled
together forever more after this but I'm
sort of getting into complaints of it so
this is the original Davros now Terry
Malloy kind of became the iconic classic
era Davros but this is Michael wisher I
actually got to originate the role and
the look is great with the you know
would be hollow sunken closed eyes and
the single dot up there and he's in the
he's in his his wheelchair that is very
reminiscent of a Dalek and you know he's
got his one hand that works and it's
misshapen and he can't move it very well
it's it's a terrific and compelling and
startling image and of course the
similarities between him and the Daleks
extends to his voice and the way he
speaks and it all it all tracks
especially the more we learn about him
his obsessions with his work with
pushing things to their utmost that if
he can do it he will just to know that
he could you know when it it's like the
Jurassic Park thing your scientists were
so busy asking about whether or not they
she whether or not they could they
didn't stop to think if they should
Davros has never even bothered to
entertain the question of whether or not
he should do anything it's just a
question of can I and if I can I will
and that comes across great here his
confrontation with the doctor the
conversation about you know creating a
virus that would you know wipe out all
life and dad were saying that he would
do it and since I mentioned the doctor
first of all great confrontations with
Davros but also Tom Baker is he's in top
form in this he has so many great
moments like excuse me can you help me
I'm a spy god I love it so much that
even these heated moments he'll flash
that that maniacal grin of his with the
big eyes is like oh but he has that
moment towards the end holding the two
bits of wire that'll set
an explosion that will destroy the Dalek
incubation room do I have the right
looking at these two pieces of wire and
it's really interesting to see that
there because most action heroes in an
action sci-fi setting would even if they
hesitate would absolutely do it for the
greater good but the doctor stops and
he's really torn up and he knows the
damage the Daleks will do he knows that
it's important that they be stopped or
slowed to something but do I have the
right and one of the things I like is
that this is something that has come up
again since then with the Daleks if you
watch remembrance of the Daleks with the
Seventh Doctor he has a conversation and
a coffee shop with the guy who works at
just about sugar cane that is basically
almost a a coda thought process almost
coming off of this do I have the right
and I feel like that that's a really
important question that the doctor in
not every incarnation but many
incarnations does ask and I think the
doctor should ask that fifth doctor
didn't he really should ask that more
often he was a trigger-happy bugger that
was an unnecessary divergence but we've
also got Harry Sullivan who I mentioned
in the opening I like Harry a lot he's
got a he's got a very easygoing rapport
with the doctor he knows how to cue off
of the doctor very well in opinions of
the doctors asking the college who have
captured them for tea and he's just like
oh yes that'd be lovely Sarah Jane is a
little bit of a mixed bag they didn't
really have all that much for her to do
she kind of gets shuttled off to
literally another location for a chunk
of the story now as a character she
still does pretty well because she's
enterprising and you know is is never
never
say die and a lot of energy but the
story doesn't have a lot of use for her
unfortunately and that does actually tie
into one of the things I am gonna
complain about I thought about this when
I was thinking about some of the well
initiative was thinking about the
cliffhangers cuz like I remember first
time watching it the cliffhanger that
made me go oh come on was surging
climbing up that scaffolding and trying
to climb out and then she falls and he
you know freeze frames and it goes to
credits I'm like Oh God's sake that's so
cheap and it is but the ultimately I can
be forgiving of the cliffhanger itself
but what's cheap about that is there's a
lot of odd little things done to extend
the time when if I'm being completely
honest I think they could probably cut
an episode out of this this could have
been a five episodes story instead of a
six so like for example Sarah Jane and
the several of the people go through
this entire attempted escape and then
get recaptured and put right back where
they were now failed escape attempts I'm
not gonna say they never work in stories
but a very classic mistake to make with
a failed escape attempt is you can't
have the characters end up back in
literally the exact same situation they
were trying to escape because then
you've you've just wasted everybody's
time you can have the escape attempt
fail but something about it has to
change security has to be tightened now
they need to like somebody who tried to
escape gets tortured as a result the
people trying to escape they didn't make
it out but they learn something about
the the people or the situation like
something has to evolve about the
situation as a result of Linnet of an
escape attempt and if it doesn't if
nothing evolves then all you did was a
little narrative circle you just ended
up right back where you were you spun
your wheels and you wasted everybody's
time and this does that it does that
also on a small scale like within an
episode and ultimately only bought them
like how
No five minutes with the time ring now
the time ring is the thing that the
doctor needs in order to get back to his
TARDIS
so through most of the story he doesn't
have it it gets taken off of him early
and they spent a long time recovering it
and then they get it and then during a
struggle with a military officer it just
comes off his wrist and he doesn't
notice until a little bit later is like
hoo hoo it's gone
and then they just go out into the
hallway and find it but it had to be
gone so that they could be stuck in a
room for a hot minute because if he'd
had it on and they could have just
gotten out of the room just by using the
time ring so they had to temporarily
take it off him literally for one scene
and or to just keep him in this location
briefly it's complete gobbledygook and
narrow narrative Lee say what was the
point of that so there's little things
like that that bug me but there's other
things that have bothered me and other
episodes that it actually uses to its
advantage some of the more antiquated
looks really speak to that because
initially you know they're in the middle
of a war but we're seeing very World War
2 era a world war one even era equipment
you know rifles and gas masks and
trenches and it's like huh this doesn't
quite match but first of all the doctor
points it out and says wow they've been
fighting for so long they've had to
resort to more more and more and more
primitive stuff because they burned
through all their high end gear fighting
this war and that's a cool idea first of
all but additional to that given that
the Daleks are and were and always have
been intended to be a very direct
allegory to the Nazis evoking you know
visually evoking the war that was fought
against the Nazis or Wars you know more
of that time that has thematic relevance
there's a reason to do that and that's
also sort of why I think they they put a
lot of thought into the design of the
uniforms
for the Cal LEDs and I also did Davros
Davros is very much a dr. mengele kind
of figure the Daleks themselves are you
know well built up they do their thing
there's but there's a good bill to them
cuz you know we see them like ha but
they're not even equipped with guns yet
and they get their guns huh well they're
not using them yet oh and they start
using them ah but they're not thinking
for themselves yet
then they start thinking for themselves
ah now we're all screwed it's a good
steady build especially considering that
it's a villain we already know we know
how this is gonna play out yet it's
still built at a nice steady pace and it
works quite well I think that's about
all I had to say this is this is better
than my memory of it was I still don't
think it's the end-all be-all of even
the fourth doctor's arrow much less all
of classic whoo the way I see so many
classic who fans really just lose their
minds over it but it is very good it
introduces a lot of good stuff it's got
some great performances especially from
Tom Baker and for Michael wisher and
it's it's a well-done piece with a
little narrative flabbiness not in its
core ideas but just in some of them just
some of the circles it runs to eat up
time and a few points that will always
bug me because I've always said at the
end of the day we're girlis of anything
else I'm a story person first so when
these things do make story decisions
that just literally go nowhere that's
always gonna bug me so there is a little
bit of that in here but it's pretty
small scale and that usually bothers me
more than it bothers other people it
seems like a lot of the time but genesis
of the Daleks
Davros Tom Baker Sarah Jane Smith good
stuff you've seen it what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff down there
to do as well because it's buttons links
you can support the patreon where you
can actually vote on classic who
episodes that I will do as video review
also it helps me pay my bills and grow
the channel and really appreciate it
and there's a bunch of other stuff down
there besides click on links they'll
take you places also the like button
smash that and subscribe hmmm also don't
do something else if you really want to
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running in the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]